scientists are likening new images from
a large asteroid to discovery of a new
world asteroid 21 leticia is located
between Jupiter and Mars and the
European Space Agency's probe receta
passed within about two thousand miles
of it its onboard camera Osiris snapping
pictures as it whizzed by we discovered
tonight in New World it's the largest
asteroid ever seen by human and is
really really exciting it's so cool
though it has been observed before by
ground-based telescopes astronomers and
graphic artists have imagined its shape
and no one is sure of what it's made out
or its origin the loot estero it is
estimated to be about 80 miles long and
its longest side it's very old perhaps
four and a half billion years of age and
shows signs of its we're boarding lots
of craters we saw really great craters
of 70 kilometers size they are like a
boat they are so large so huge and they
are covered soon most of them of the
larger craters they have a very round
rim so they are very very old traders so
it's well it's discovery so we have a
lot of large craters tons of all the
traitors tons of small craters even
smaller innocently and the large craters
so it's a lot of topography a lot of
excitement we don't understand right now
and that will keep us busy for months
and years working these these images esh
probe made its flyby Saturday capping a
tense weekend for scientists at the
agency's Darmstadt Germany operation
center who have guided the Rosetta
spacecraft since its launch more than
six years ago they will spend several
weeks receiving transmission of the 400
images of leticia it captured
you